[Applaudissements]
etc
bah non ouais
[Musique]
michel
[Applaudissements]
oui
et sans
et
trois couleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
je vais manger ne plus dormir bras
hamon
[Musique]
jours
le journée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais camair de mon stylo je dois d'être
avec nous j'étais bien herbert et julie
il était beau ce magnifique julie piétri
mais ils sont toujours otages vous les
voyez toujours oui monsieur contact
julie grandes chanteuses herbert ce très
grand chanteur français normative la
huawei enfin bon on a fait on a fait dix
ans ensemble ouais j'ai dû écrire 30
chansons pour eux non va pour enfin pour
celles là pour le duo et une trentaine
pour herbert il m'a dit moi toutes les
vérités comme ça sur la route comme ça
comment ça peut rapporter une chanson
comme ça encore aux endroits pas rassuré
sur pour le plaisir
on a fêté les quarante hommes - plaisir
ce sont 1000 euros un truc comme ça non
aujourd'hui quand ça m'a trop touba par
an
chaque année
je compte pas du nord
sylvie vartan mais non elle pêche à j'ai
adoré cette chanson là nous avions vu ta
venue un soir pour michel nuit d'avion
asseoir vue d'avion un soir je connais
pas ça l'amusé l'espèce
de bourgeois qui devrait passer à
jacques amsellem enfin compris la télé
régis est la variété content de te voir
jean jacques elle c'est la merde on joue
à tout le monde
[Musique]
l'essai
le
[Musique]
m
en fait il me semble musicale ici depuis
tout à l'heure en fait que chanter way
le chanteur qui a fait born to be alive
entre eux entre 2000 et 2500 jours
c'est ça se joue c'est un des morceaux
les plus incroyables minimum 1500 euros
par jour encore aujourd'hui incroyable
alors géré et comment ça va mais je suis
content de vous voir ça faisait
longtemps que j'avais pas vu maire de
bages t'embrasse très fort alors que
chez lui et ses bouteilles d'eau matière
isabelle jean-jacques les mécènes en
régie c'est marrant parce que ma mère
trop when the saints terrible il est
beau bertrand je crois que je t'aime
bertrand c'est
incroyable parce que je les ai vus hier
soir non avec la famille monaco oui
c'est dans l'espoir ministère oui
manille film les intérêts sur métaphore
super je peux lui tombera cgt dockers
[Applaudissements]
on était en train de faire un carton sur
la cible gay depuis le début d'émission
quoi les couples se forment au calme je
me crée actuellement formés au calme et
à la levée ou non mais si besoin qu'on
vous aime aussi ça vous ne manquent pas
justement tous à la télé là elle le fait
bien d'autres trucs en ce moment ouais
notamment de la crypto crypto bonnet
la crypto fasciste parents trouvent en
dire mais dans les rings les digues ça
s'appelle déry gilad et des voiliers des
espèces de supports sur lesquels tu mets
des comment s'appellent les cartes
graphiques pour miner de la crypto
monnaie ouais parce que c'est pas du
tout la question c'était la télé là ce
que tu vois alors je te demande tu vois
je vous regarde beaucoup oui c'est bien
c'est bien aujourd'hui merci
c'est gentil mais sec non voilà non il
est bon de revenir bas pour faire un bon
truc oui ouais si l'on mange pas
chroniqueur souple et chroniqueur
qui était possible pour ce beau jeux oui
bien sûr j'aimerais bien si ici aussi on
se marre ouais c'est intéressant pour
tout le monde
fleischer adversaires je ne sais pas
il ya des gays il ya des montants que
les sorties mais moi ça me choque pas
dit à l'époque vous veniez entre 40000
et 50000 euros par mois quand vous devez
vous poser des questions pour un
champion c'est vrai ça on peut soulever
sans doute vers l'est dans les quarante
mille ouais c'est ça il faut que tu aies
faut tout de suite ab je jouis 50%
d'impôt battant fabien s'est ensuite
bien sûr à quand tu lis par devrait
ensuite à des tas de frais des tas de
trucs pour justement pour pour la
télévision que qui seront à chacun sur
et puis voilà mais je me plains pas du
tout il est polyvalent vous êtes une
énorme star juin le monde vous connaît
et tout lé général c'est parce que c'est
laisser la durée ses 30 ans 30 ans tous
les jours on entend tous les jours et 50
pays dans le monde du sport aux côtés
d'anecdotes pardon je vous raconte une
anecdote ma grand-mère de que j'adorais
oui comme ma mère quand je l'appelais il
ya un horaire où je ne pourrais pas 18
ans exactement à cette heure là je
regarde
je crois mais un coin vous étiez sont ni
d'odeur si elle savait que je vous
reçois aujourd'hui c'est quand même
c'est que tu vas toujours pas nom est
partie elle est partie annoncé la
cession j'aurais dit non parce que
vraiment on allait le faire ah ba
amer l'a fait pape aussi là j'avoue
c'est compliqué avant d'appeler à
quelqu'un de l'au-delà assez compliqué
actionnant leurs appelé à merde sérieuse
pour ses armes chez lepers
vous avez trois phrases jetées dans vos
émissions est ce que vous pouvez me le
répéter mais mais mais baver à son ex
époux rené joly je lis je te pète afin
que vous avez prévu un repas préparé une
que cette annonce est pas prêt de
questions alors je suis je suis je suis
à peu près de questions non j'ai bien
mis ces lois là je suis je suis je suis
voilà exactement ce qui augmente dans le
ton et tu accélères yann perreau je suis
je suis ouais ouais et à tant que
candidat oui oui donc ça ça c'est après
oui il est beau bon jeu il est beau jeu
c'est parti
est ce que est ce que est ce que vous en
voulez toujours à dallas tire pas la
personne de france télévisions tu sais
où comme ça tout ça derrière j'ai envie
de vivre bien ouais et de mourir de
mourir sans comment je le dis sans
regret sans problème oui c'est ça
ouais parce que c'est une horreur c'est
pas bon pour la santé voilà dana qui m'a
mis dehors le mais d'autres aussi de
trois courts pas été coup mais c'est
tout ouais on n'y pense plus ça fait
trois quatre cinq ans déjà non ça fait
trois quatre cinq ans mais malgré tout
les gens vous connaissent toujours pas
malgré tout ça s'est fait dans des
conditions qui n'étaient pas très classe
non je vous aviez des aussi à l'époque
il ya sept courses un peu au jeunisme à
part michel drucker culture là on est en
train de mettre un petit peu tous les
animateurs comme un star d'un âge d'or
ban comment david pujadas dehors william
leymergie dehors partir d'or gérard
holtz dehors pernoud dehors de peur d'or
bon c'est tout moi je le sais tout je me
dis que ça mais est ce que c'est normal
ou pas normal jamais anticipé vous
saviez pas con et que vous étiez dans un
milieu un peu impitoyable finalement et
que ça pouvait arriver vous y aviez
pensé voilà très juste très bonne
remarque du bo j'adore
j'étais dans un an peut-être un autre
monde j'étais vraiment la tête dans le
guidon je l'aï beaucoup ouais pour faire
cesser ça marchait bien mais ça demande
beaucoup de travail en amont est donc je
ne pensais pas que ça pouvait m'arriver
disons d'une heure à l'autre d'une rallo
par la seule volonté de quelqu'un qui a
décidé qu'il y avait trop d'hommes
blancs d'oeufs puis de 50 ans fallait
que ça change à 3 discrimination dans la
même phrase puni par la loi
les corps mais quand une nation de sexe
de race et de et d'âge et je mets qu'en
france télévisions après on parlera plus
jamais mais disait que vous étiez
ingérable surtout l'absolu où se
trouvent ces fosses comment aurais-je pu
être ingérable pendant 30 ans n'a pas
hésité sahara pendant pendant deux mois
trois mois ouais peut-être mais
pendant trente ans c'est bien un truc
quand même deux mais à quelque chose pas
avec une chose nous dit
maintenant il n'ya pas si longtemps j'ai
rencontré quelqu'un qui a très bien
connu madame micheline ça venant chose
madame micheline la mission n'a pas dit
non c'est non c'est gris mais j'étais
une fille de vos chevaux et elle
racontait manhattan
ont plutôt
été jugé bon de la poudre de lits
commodes d'accord est très utilisé dans
mais bien sur wii sa bouche les lego
quand tu as des comment s'appelle des
cheveux qui te mords way montre moi ton
[Applaudissements]
de la poudre et de josé anigo de
voirie dans tout parce qu'il est jeune
il faut faire attention le greta adore
la poutre d'hélico
non non non c'est surtout un abus de
fonds oui oui julien une question vous
avez déclaré que vous aviez eu pendant
30 ans 99% de bonheur et 1 800 de
délicatesse on va dire avec notamment
cette éviction et vous avez rajouté que
vous n'arriviez pas vous n'aviez pas
envie de regarder aujourd'hui questions
pour un champion mais est-ce que de
temps en temps quand même quand on a pu
ne jamais présenter un programme comme
ça pendant 30 ans a dit ce type à un peu
d'aller voir ce que fait le nécessaire
je te réponds tout de suite moi je n'ai
aucun goût pour le masochiste je ne suis
pas masochiste à manille dehors on m'a
montré la porte à la bim-sa défaut
bertrand et referme la porte et on fait
autre chose et merci d'ailleurs de
m'inviter c'est gentil merci denis
riedinger une question que je me pose
des questions comme vous êtes un homme
de spectacle à un homme de chaud oui
mais ça va est ce que vous êtes en
couple c'est quoi un peu la vie devait
être en couple vous vivez seul vous
habitez ou union demandé aux communes
310 à pas nous
[Rires]
mais j'ai fait que les gens veulent
savoir mais il vous aime et c'est pas
dire des choses des choses justes me
dire voilà est-ce qu'on n'est diffusé
que dans le marais
[Applaudissements]
la chercher celle là tu l'as cherché
c'est drôle mais c'est pas ma question
la question c'est est-ce que c'est ma
vie privée mais oui si du chabab se
soient privés de vie non kaka comme
salle indique j'ai une vie privée oui
mais comme audi privé les sorties a pas
très longtemps y a pas de vie prévue
surtout bien longtemps à badens tpm paix
avec cyril l'autre jour oui ça c'est pas
cool ce que vous avez fait d'ailleurs
alors je te le dis je
crache laisseront seconde je peux du
coup ce n'est pas celle extrait parce
qu'il est aujourd'hui un champ que
j'aime ou je viens chez obligé bazille
ok j'y vais voilà c'était un garçon qui
est venu qui a prétendu à votre fils
regardé c'était dans tpm paix définitif
oui savoir si vous étiez vraiment le
fils de oui oui on a fait des tests dont
il a eu trois le premier était à 81 18 9
ou quelque chose comme ça c'était
extrêmement probant mais il a demandé
une contre-expertise c'est descendu
ensuite entre 60 et 70 et puis non on a
demandé une autre et c'est descendu à 55
donc comprends pas trop pourquoi la
première période mais réaliste sûr que
c'est jouir le père de ma mère je vais
poser beaucoup de fois la question quand
j'étais petit parce que c'est quand même
gros mais bon elle sait ce qu'elle a
fait quoi j'aimerais savoir d'où je
viens et puis aussi j'ai une demi soeur
avec qui j'ai encore des contacts plus
ou moins donc on a failli faire les
tests de notre côté mais apparemment
elle a dû lui dire certainement par
respect pour lui et ça lui a pas plu du
tout donc ça s'est pas fait mais on
allait faire ça de notre côté c'est pour
ça aussi j'aime bien vous soyez là comme
ça vous pouvez tout dire alors je ne
vais pas regarder l'émission n'aurions
de la vie c'est ma fille qui me l'a dit
ouais je t'embrasse lorraine oui donc
elle me l'a dit mais je n'avais pas pas
mais qu'est ce qui se passe pour donc gg
de rêve enfin je me suis fait raconter
ce qui s'était passé ici la moindre des
choses je le dis à cyril à travers toi
c'est quand tu fais un truc comme ça tut
tut tut tut invite la partie adverse
c'est qu'elle puisse répondre oui ça se
fait tout seul le mec peut pas répondre
à prendre nous avez pas vous n'avez pas
eu le droit qu'à droite abc n'a pu
attaquer
mais bon ce n'est pas le débat on veut
pas le savoir rien dire est ce que les
gens qui parlent de toiles route voilà
donc
un garçon qui tient une grande s'appelle
un test de paternité que j'ai demandé
évidemment oui ce test a été négatif
qu'est-ce que je peux faire de plus en
plus je crois qu'il a 34 35 ans et je
crois que au bout de 28 ans on ne peut
plus rien faire du tout d'accord en plus
j'ai d'autres choses que je peux dire
mais c'est difficile à dire maintenant
en public ils sont pas très agréables
pour toutes ces raisons là je te dis que
c'est non d'accord on ne sait très bien
d'ailleurs moi je l'aï vu une fois donc
rien alors c'est quoi l'intérêt de
quelques années sans intérêt lui barrent
j'en sais rien l'argent aux américains
ils aborder ou quoi oui je ne sais pas
mais jamais fois anna mais lui l'a dit à
98% l'adn c'était oui avec vous et après
il y en a fait un deuxième test qu'elle
fut tel qu'il le dit que c'est vrai j'ai
mes genoux il faut les deux parties
fassent ça pour ça c'est pour ça que
c'est difficile de faire ça dans une
émission de télévision et je comprends
et je compris moi ce qui m'a surpris
c'est le tout d'un coup je n'étais pas
au courant je doive garçons car éduquer
ivg bertrand deckers que le cas
physiquement ils vous ressemblent non
tassia côté de moi exact
d'ailleurs c'est un peu vrai y sont
beaucoup
mais non mais ça c'est pas poli laiterie
détritus bon alors voilà trente secondes
voilà ce que j'avais à dire c'est tous
les cieux mais c'est pour ça on va pas
plus loin oui les divines petite
question qui n'a rien à proposer autre
chose je trouvais pas mieux pour
l'emmerder là dessus si c'est bien parce
que je me prends des bons alors dans
l'éviction de on alors qu'il ya autre
chose
l'éviction normal c'est une vraie
question de plaisir vous avez parlé d'un
livre vérité que vous étiez en train
d'écrire alors contre x concernant votre
vie alors
il est sorti je les
ai veillé pendant la sieste
c'est ce que je sais moi j'étais en
train gare dans l'oreillette en irak de
la mer avec toutes ces polémiques alors
viens petit peu sur la télé on
remarquera merde mais les mines ses
sorties
je suis je suis je suis aux éditions
flammarion
alors oui la promo quoi ce que tu poses
julien toudic cinéma dans le cinéma on
n'a quand même pas mal de chaîne on
n'est pas ce que vous avez un sosie vous
le savez
sonia croyable
encore une vraie michael keaton michael
mais ce n'est plus vrai c'est moi qui
veut faire le prochain batman et vous
pourriez pas encore des personnes
étaient cuites moscou par passe de votre
première télé c'était quand or là il ya
débat là dessus il me semble que les
débats surtout vous en votre vie vos
bouquins c'était il ya il ya très
longtemps loin une émission de
télévision de de l'accordéon pour lé
avec albert raisner ou là est-ce qu'on a
nous y voilà je crois que dans la rue et
je pense pas que vous l'ayez
alors je vais dire autre chose oui juste
après ouais
les gains
de 2
pour la réponse de bras
je retrouve à l'animateur a hit parade
même celui qui nous apporte soleil il
est venu de la côte ça va il fait beau
là bas
notre ami julien les perses de radio
monte carlo bonsoir à tous c'est lui qui
maintenant va gueuler les performances
des cinq chansons en compétition la
première chinoise et rimbo le pop
concerto voilà c'est sa chance au numéro
un chinois he the rainbow par le pop
concerto orchestra qui fait une très
très belle carrière au hit parade mais
qui hélas on est sorti maintenant une
parade bagarre entre ea sûrement numéro
un chinois
[Applaudissements]
et quelle carrière vient de temps ça va
je sais pas et ça date de quand sa dette
de 4 9 1975 ce terrain j'avais 25 ans
elle faisait part à deux relais du
fairway j'ai fait pendant cinq ans et
l'âge avec l'autre en soi qui venaient
me voir cette époque avait que 5 radio
france et claude il voulait être numéro
un au hit parade de radio monte carlo
l'été tu vois il savait que la france et
100 des dons dans le sud il venait me
voir moi j'avais 23 24 ans la
gt gt tu vois j'étais gamin wickham a et
je voyais débarquer claude immense
vedette il mentionnait tu vises et
julien est ce que je peux tu es invité
ce soir on est une tablée de devin de 25
au martinez succès à canet et je venais
de voir de temps en temps parce qu'ils
espéraient que propose un numéro où il
parle mais s'accroît quand je voyais des
barques et michel berger france gall joe
dassin malbranque marlboro rachat le
succès
oui 2 my brand jouer on y avait des
grands couloirs à radio monte carlo elle
lui court après ce cachet dans l'est
dans lesquelles il avait une trouille
scène mais neuf de ses filles
hystériques c'est vrai il reste une
maison près je voyais tout c'est joël il
était une fois je pense beaucoup pas à
elle en ce moment et et vous rêviez 3 à
cette époque c'est quoi alors votre
votre ambition vous vouliez faire de la
télé vous les sortez envoyé à la hausse
il est décidément un briquet turgot je
connais pas que moi ou comment faire de
la musique je vais faire une chanson
c'était ça monte rural influence de vos
parents ou pas vraiment mon père chef
d'orchestre
la mère maria chanteuse d'accord et et
ça m'a mené à la musique tout de suite
tu vois j'ai préféré continuer avec la
télévision qui me souriait bien sûr
voilà et oui est-ce qu'on passe un peu à
ma mère un petit best-of quand même pour
les gens de julien lepers dans nos
questions pour un champion on peut bien
sûr que cette tournée mission non non
c'est notre émission quand vous êtes
assez vite chaque jour métro n'est pas
reprenez le charisme c'est vous c'est
vous le charisme je suis un serviteur
l'impulsion j'ai une question à merde je
vois pour un champion
mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir et comment
vous dire le bonheur que j'ai de vous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle émission
ce nouveau jeu sur un fer 3 7 française
donnez m'en donnez donnez donnez donnez
donnez moi oui oui
oui
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
l énergie
quand tu fasse le show parce que si tu
prends un journaliste qui qui qui dit
les questions quand même comme il
annonce une nouvelle comme ça c'est
toute la ville est la différence entre
un journaliste et un animateur ouais
faut que tu fasses le show que tu met de
l'ambiance tout en faisant les choses
sérieusement c'est ça bien sûr vous et
régions déjà essayé de faire pendant une
trentaine d'années et c'était très
réussi alors vous êtes juste un petit et
demi c'était parti cela bon j'ai pas
compris vous aviez un petit et demi
c'était patricia pour la musique dans le
milieu ça non je ne vais pas vous
entendez pas très bien si tu arrives
avec et avait pas que vous n'avez pas à
terville ensemble mais ça s'est pas bien
passé c'est vrai tout neuf à six il le
dit je veux c'est peut-être son avis
mais c'est pas le bien du tout et non
j'aime bien m'a regardé cette histoire
était monté oui camarades de la leaf
puis c'est la fameuse gifle qui avait
donné toutes veulent agir il donne une
gifle à un moment donné à arras partout
et lui dit que cette gifle pierre mas
que brouiller tout ça qui est passé
c'est vous qui avez mis ça rend en
lumière parce que ça se passait mal avec
lui je sais même pas de quoi tu parles
et c'est pour ça ouais franchement il
faut passer un mois on parlait de
l'importance s'arrêter là moi j'aime
bien ça se passe je sais qu'à une promo
aussi promo lepers mes chers parents mes
jeunes parents mes chers parents c'est
le disque près la peau frais ouais 2 2 3
cd avec raymond le
chef d'orchestre il accompagne et paul
anka ouais à la grande époque de paul
anka l'immense artiste vraie pointure
d'ailleurs la couture et dans le match
odeurs et sa faute en garde à vous
regarder isabelle
bah oui
voyez les quads hawsawi et georges ulmer
absolument et rappelle isabelle le jour
des noms à
[Rires]
la grande époque de georges ulmer
arrête de plaisanter parce que c'était
deux grands artistes mais bien sûr lanka
est toujours sur la route ouais bah oui
comme toujours très grand très grand
chanteur je plaisante pas du beau père
accompagné ces artistes là ils se sont
connus à perdre on perd dans les
coulisses des spectacles je suis né et
peut-être cet avis oui c'est dans les
gènes tu vois ça se construit voilà
parce que moi ce que je note c'est vous
c'est multi talents c'est à dire
composite derrière la musique
l'animation j'aime la vie on aura le
temps de se reposer plus tard way we de
la vie voilà j'ai pas envie de perdre de
temps ouais avec des imbéciles avec des
dés des gens néfastes agents toxiques
toxiques auxi c'est le mot absolument si
moi j'avais bien qu'on ne revoit jamais
poussée de fièvre jaune ou encore les
adore ben moi je suis vous êtes là il ya
une énergie à quelque chose
tout est possible tout c'est à dire pas
pour la télé j'entendais bah oui je suis
d'ailleurs
très bien et devait compliquer quoi mais
j'aimais rien compris mais comme vous
draguez battre avec herschel dire que
jane ou non pas du tout non mais alors
lire soir que j'ai vu non c'est bien à
monaco ouais vous m'avez dit maintenant
tu m'as appris quelque chose jamais
avoir je sais pas si on peut y revenir
bien sûr je ne savais pas ça c'est grâce
à toi finale après ça c'était le
meilleur quand même de albert prévu une
troisième affaire à merde c'est la
dernière affaire je ne savais pas
j'avais passé quoi la faire à la
dernière affaire aille troisième affaire
de paternité c'est
toi qui m'a prise ailleurs et le mystère
von bülow
qu'il jouait le rôle qu'ils jouent les
deux principaux rôles dans le cerveau de
boulot je ne sais pas qui tu es alors je
crois que je sais c'est vrai jean claude
willem clause sait pas où on va
mais là où le film est en effet pas
remettre à la mode ce scandale
incroyable qui a eu lieu il a quasiment
tué son épouse avait été dit elle sans
à-coups dass jennir de dsk est ce qu'on
peut dire un mot
juste il ya un mot que vous les gens me
bertrand deckers à propos de nouvelles
séries de couronnes c'est vrai ah oui
sur la syrie au créneau et gégé j'ai lu
ça un truc incroyable ce que c'est une
série qui marche mondialement qui
raconte la vie dallas la reine elizabeth
ii
depuis sa jeunesse jusqu'à maintenant
tous les deux ont du coup il change
d'acteurs tous les acteurs de séries
change pour s'adapter à l'âge des
acteurs et en ce moment ils préparent la
sixième saison tu as 5e sont nos ventes
et pour la 6éme y cherche désespérément
dans toute l'angleterre mais celle qui
pourrait incarner kate middleton il
s'engager ou que la famille royale de
trouver une actrice que ce soit aussi
jolie pikmin l'étonnante si bien et s'il
la trouve pas eh ben la sixième saison
capotera pavés du coin car tu sais jean
michel chine s'inquiète pas trop où on
va envoyer
[Musique]
mais l'organe instant